[MUSIC]
I was in the seventh grade, and it was
the day before the animal science fair.
Now, I was the undisputed
Queen of the science field.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Not because I was a science nerd, but
because I had a very innovative model.
And this time, we have made
a beautiful model of the solar system.
Not only were the planets
scaled to perfection, but
they also rotated around the sun as
we had a small motor in the center.
That motor had cost me
all my pocket money.
Now midnight before the big day,
I thought I just tried one last time.
I flip the on switch and it didn't work.
My heart beating faster I tried
it again and again, but nothing.
I shouted for my mum and
she came running inside the room.
She took one look at the model and
understood the problem.
Looking around the room she thought for a
minute, she then smiled, turned around and
remove the clock from the ward.
She unscrewed the hands carefully and
pasted the sun in the center.
She flicked the on switch.
It was magic.
It was incredibly.
Now this moment of
ingenuity fascinated me.
Why hadn't I thought of
the clock instead of that
bulky noisy motor in the first place?
I realized that this creativity had only
been possible due to the force time and
resource constraints.
Over the years, I observed this process
several times across many incidents and
identified a very strange theme.
Creativity loves constraints.
And why is that?
Fewer constraints means more choice.
And choice is paralyzing.
We humans are terrible at decision making.
How many of you have given
up on watching the movie
after spending hours
flicking through Netflix?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Constraints actually give
us the building blocks to
start experimenting with.
In a recent experiment participants
were divided into two groups and
asked to compose rhymes.
One group was given a set of eight
randomly generated nouns and
the other group was free to use
whichever words they wanted.
>> Judges evaluated their rhymes and
was surprised to find that the group
that was working under constraints
had more creative, more novel times.
Yes, creativity loves constraints.
In India, often capital and regulatory
constraints are a way of life for
entrepreneurs and creativity thrives.
We even have a Hindi word for that.
It's called Jugaad.
Jugaad is a flexible approach to problem
solving that stems from a can do attitude.
It is a mental leap that permits one to
accept that challenge of constraint and
leads to destructive designs in products.
And this concept is not just Indian.
Take the example of Israel,
a nation that has combated war and
intelligence with unparalleled innovation,
earning it the name startup nation.
During a study trip I interacted with
local entrepreneurs and I was surprised
to find that they actually attributed
Israel successes to its constraints.
But I also heard stories, where the
concept of Jugaag was met with disdain and
rejection.
While working in Mumbai,
my favorite hangout place was this rooftop
restaurant opposite my office building.
One night, there was a massive
fire that destroyed the place.
It was a horrific incident 14 people died.
The reason had been an illegal bamboo
roof structure that caught fire easily.
The owners were not able to
get the approvals on time and
had resorted to this quick fix
to deal with that constraint.
Four weeks after that,
I could see the side ashes and
the wood remains of the rooftop
front of window near my work desk.
It was a painful bench that
served as a constant reminder
that working around constraints could
lead to disastrous consequences.
I lost strong hope Jugaad was going
to be overtaken, watered down and
used as an excuse for sloppy thinking.
And this grace Smith's application
of creativity makes me angry.
If you can make a low quality,
dangerous product at a low budget,
how is that creativity?
If you can break the law to deal with
that constraint, how is that creativity.
Creativity is that handheld ECG
monitor made by GE scientists at
a fraction of the original cost, but has
saved millions of lives in rural India.
Creativity is a beautiful baby
incubator made by GSB alumni,
which had to be made
at a fraction of cost.
It was even better than the original
concept because it allowed the mother to
hold the baby while it
was being incubated.
While working in Mumbai,
I was working on a development project
to increase literacy in rural Rajasthan.
And I came across a tricky problem.
I noticed that students were
unable to go to school and
have continued education because they
were traveling for several months.
They traveled on camel back for several
days at a stretch with their tribes and
communities.
Now given the limited
funds at my disposal,
I could not solve this problem by going
about building schools in the desert.
I considered using technology and
maybe providing tablets to the tribes.
But the because of the limited
access to electricity and
internet, this would have never worked.
Given the cost, and technology, and
location constraints, I needed a Jugaad.
But dashes was still fresh in my memory.
I needed a solution that could
speak to my concept of Jugaad.
I needed a solution that could work
within the constraints and yet
trumped the traditional solution
in its quality and utility.
Identifying the problem I thought
that if the kids could not
go to school because they were traveling
what if the school went with them.
We designed the idea of a mobile school,
which was a simple cart on
wheels furnished with books,
chart paper or Blackboard, and then we
trained a few teachers in every community.
Things fell into place.
This initiative transformed
the lives of nomadic communities.
We realized that not just kids
even the adults had a lot of
idle time while travelling for
days at a stretch.
This easy access to books and
teachers stole their curiosity and
they started attending
the modern school as well.
With the cascading effect the entire
community started becoming literate.
Next time when you are faced
with an innovation challenge,
be it to design a new product, launch
a new strategy, or even to prepare your
evening meal, I invite you to think about
my story and try these three steps.
One, identify the underlying need.
For us, the need was not building schools.
It was educating the children.
Two recognize your constraints.
We needed a solution that would
work within our location,
time capital constraints.
And if there aren't any constraints
fit yourself with seemingly
unattainable goals in terms of delivery
time, functionality or inputs.
Challenge yourself to prepare that
meal with just four ingredients.
Challenge yourself to sketch that
first prototype in one hour and
experiment with that.
Remember, creativity loves constraints.
Three and the most important believe
that you can solve the problem.
Jugaad thinking is a leap of faith that
needs a lot of experimentation and
may result in failure.
So brace yourself.
We did not know if the community
would even accept the solution
of a school traveling with them,
but they welcomed it.
An year after the launch, an 85 year old
man from the community wrote me a letter.
It said, because of you,
no one will say that I died illiterate.
Feeling that letter my faith
in Jugaad thinking was reborn.
A Jugaad is what allowed me to
impact him and thousands of others.
Jugaad was that aha moment when I
solved the puzzle of constraints.
A Jugaad is that gift my mom gave me when
she solved my model years and years ago.
A Jugaad is my offering to you.
And next time when you are faced
with an innovation challenge,
shackle yourself with constraints and
unleash the freedom of creativity.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]